[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ماذا يحدث في السودان اليكم ما
نعرفه حتى هذه اللحظه اندلعت مواجهه مسلحه
ما بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بقياده الفريق محمد حمدان ديجلو صباح يوم
السبت الموافق 15 ابريل 2023
[موسيقى]
من اطلق الرصاص الاولى ليس واضحا لان
الطرفين يتبادلان الاتهامات بان الطرف
الاخر هو من بادره بالعدوان عليه اندلاع
المواجهات ما بين الجيش والدعم السريع امر
مؤسف
ماساوي يصعب التنبؤ بنتائجه لكنه لم يكن
مفاجئا ابدا لان التوتر يتصاعد ما بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع منذ شهور اسباب
الخلاف التي ادت الى المواجهه المسلحه
تقتدي ان نحك القصه من البدايه
واسهل بدايه لهذه القصه السيئه هو لحظه
سقوط الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر حسن
البشير يوم 11 ابريل 2019 لكن قبل ان
نستطرد فيه شرح جذور الخلاف الذي ادى الى
هذه المواجهات المسلحه من المهم ان اذكر
غير السودانيين بامرين بسيطين الامر الاول
ما هي قوات الدعم السريع ومن هو رئيسها
محمد حمدان دجله الشهير بحميتين
قوات الدعم السريع هي جهاز امني انشاه
الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر حسن البشير في
سنه 2013
الهدف المعلن منها هو حفظ الامن
واستقرار البلاد والمحافظه على الحدود
ومواجهه الجريمه المنظمه القوام الاساسي
لها هم رجال الميليشيات الشهيره باسم
الجنجاويد التي شاركت فيه ضرب وقمع
المتمردين على الحكومه المركزيه في منطقه
دارفور
الميليشيات دي او جهاز الدعم السريع النشا
في البدايه كفرع من جهاز الامن والمخابرات
السوداني الهدف الحقيقي كما يعلم الكثيرين
من العالمين بواطن الامور في السودان لم
يكن كما هو على الورق يعني المساهمه في
حفظ الامن لان كان في جيش وكان في شرطه
ولكن كان هدفا يتعلق بحواجز الرئيس
السوداني السابق اللي كان مسكون بفكره ان
ينقلب عليه الجيش كمنقلب هو على من سبقه
وبالتالي كان حريصا على استخدام هذه
الميليشيات التي اثبتت ولائها له اثناء
الحرب على المتمردين في دارفور
لانشاء جهاز اخر يمكن ان يركن اليه ان
انقلب الجنرالاته عليه
واختار طبعا السيد محمد حمدان دجله ليكون
رئيسا
لهذا الجهاز الجديد الهدف من الجهاز واضح
في اللقب اللي كان احيانا بيستخدمه عمر
حسن البشير في وصف محمد حمدان ديجلو فبدل
ما يصفه بحمدتي كان بيقول حمايتي هذا
حمايتي ايمن اثق فيه لحمايته من هو محمد
حمدان دجله هذا بقى ليس واضحا تماما بمعنى
انه في علامات استفهام على يعني هويته
ونشاته وصعوده الى راس السلطه لكن
المعلومات المتداوله بين كل القوى
السودانيه ان الرجل حاصل على تعليم متوسط
وانه عمل في بدايه حياته في مجال التجاره
وخصوصا تجاره الابل والجمال ثم انتقل من
هذه التجاره لتكوين جماعات مسلحه لحفظ
القوافل التجاريه في المناطق المنفلته
سواء على الحدود السودانيه او في الدول
المجاوره ثم بهذه الخلفيه بدا ينضم الى
الميليشيات المسلحه اللي هي الجنجويد التي
اسسها البشير
لمواجهه القبائل الافريقيه تحديدا او نقول
المتمردين بصفه عامه في دارفور من الواضح
ان كان عنده قدرات استثنائيه لفتت نظر عمر
حسن البشير فاهتم به كثيرا ورقه من فرد
عالي الى ان اعطاه رتبا عسكريه بدءا من
رتبه ملازم ثم نقيب ثم عميت الى ان قرر ان
يعطيه رتبه فريق في سنه 2017
وطبعا هو فريق وقائد للقوات الدعم السريع
نعود مره اخرى الى اسباب الخلاف اللي انا
كنت بتكلم عليها الا ادت الى الوضع
الماساوي الحالي في السودان
سقط الرئيس عمر حسن البشير يوم 11 ابريل
2019 كيف سقط ولماذا سقط هو سقط بسبب
الاحتجاجات المدنيه
المستمره لشهور ضد حكمه لكن هذه
الاحتجاجات المستمره من القوى المدنيه
كانت كافيه للضغط على النظام واحراجه ولم
تكن كافيه لاسقاطه الرجل سقط سقط بعد ان
قررت القوات العسكريه سواء القوات المسلحه
او قوات الدعم السريع ان تدير ظهرها الى
البشير وتنضم الى المحتجين وبالتالي سقط
يوم 11 ابريل 2019 فرح الشعب واعتقد ان
احلامه تحققت
وبدات مطالب
المدنيين يعني تكون جامحه جدا تخيلوا ان
السودان الان على اعتاب مرحله يمكن ان
تتحقق فيها دوله مدنيه ديموقراطيه يلعب
فيها الجيش الدور التقليدي الذي يلعبه في
الديمقراطيات وهو حفظ الامن فقط لا غير
الجيش كان عنده تصور اخر احنا اسقطنا عمر
حسن البشير فقط لانه يعني اصبح وجها
محروقا ونحن نرغب في استمرار النظام مع
تغييرات طفيفه وهي التغييرات ديت عباره عن
الوجوه الغير مرغوبه اللي كان على راسها
عمر حسن البشير نفسه بدا الصدامه مبكرا ما
بين المكون العسكري الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع من ناحيه وما بين القوات المدنيه
من ناحيه اخرى وظلت هذه الخلافات في شكل
جذب ومد لشهور طويله مرت بمراحل مختلفه
ومنها مواجهات وعمليه قتل متهم فيها
بالمناسبه قوات الدعم السريع وبعض فصائل
الجيش لكن قوات الدعم السريعه على وجه
التحديد لكن دي قصص عرفها الناس واطول
شرحها على كل على كل الاحوال
استمرت مراحل الكذب والشد الى ان قرر
الجيش في 25 طبعا اثناء مراحل الجذب والشد
ديت تكون مج لس سياده هو المجلس الحاكم
للسودان مكون من 11 شخص
خمس عسكريين خمس مدنيين ومدني اخر يختاره
الطرفان يعني 11 شخص منهم نصفهم عسكريين
ونصفهم مدنيين اختصارا يعني
في 25
اكتوبر 2021 قرر الفريق البرهان بدعم من
الفريق حمدان ديجلو الانقلاب على المكون
المدني
وقالوا عبد الله حمدوك الذي كان رئيس
الوزراء في ذلك الوقت وضعه تحت الاقامه
الجبريه وسرحوا كل المسؤولين المدنيين في
المجلس العسكري وحل الحكومه واعلنوا احكام
الطوارئ انقلب المجتمع الدولي انقلب الراي
العام الداخلي اضطر الفريق البرهان
للتراجع واعاد رئيس الوزراء عبد الله
حمدوك
في الشهر التالي وبرر ما فعله بانها كانت
مرحله الهدف منها تصحيح مسار المرحله
الانتقاليه وانه عازم على استعاده زخم
المرحله الانتقاليه املين في الوصول الى
حكومه مدنيه مستقره وان يعود الجيش الى
سكناته كما يقولون
عبد الله حمدوك اضطر ان يستقيل في عاده في
الشهر التالي استقال في يناير 2022
استقال بسبب صعوبه الاجواء التي يعني يعمل
فيها الرجل يعني كل منقسم على الكل في
السودان المدنيين منقسمين على المدنيين
العسكريين منقسمين على العسكريين
والعسكريين منقسمين وفي صراع مع المدنيين
ودي قصه السودان يعني اللي ممكن نتعرض
اليها بالتفصيل في وقت اخر على كل الاحوال
بداوا مرحله انتقاليه المكونه العسكري
الجيش
والقوات الدعم السريع مع القوى المدنيه
التي ابدت استعدادها للتعامل مع العسكريين
لان في قوه مدنيه رفضت التعامل معاهم من
الاساس
وبعد نحو سنه توصلوا الى صيغه عباره عن
خريطه طريق للوصول الى حكومه مدنيه ودوله
مدنيه مستقره توصلوا الى هذه الصيغه التي
عرفت باسم الاتفاق الاطاري في ديسمبر 2022
الاتفاق الاقاري وقع عليه البرحان وقع
عليه محمد حمدان دقل ووقع عليه قوات قوى
مدنيه حوالي 40 حزبا وعرضه اخرون كثيرون
لكن هذه قصه يطول شرحها وباركه المجتمع
الدولي كله في احتفاليه كبيره الاتفاق
الاطاري ضم بنود واعده جدا تشبه يعني
الدرافت او المواثيق او الاس اللي بتتبني
عليها
دساتير الدول الديمقراطيه المستقره على كل
الاحوال الاتفاق الاطاري ده تحدث عن امور
كثيره منها اقامه سلطه مدنيه كامله دون
مشاركه القوات العسكريه اللي هي النظاميه
تنظيم عمليه انتخابيه شامله في نهايه
الفتره الانتقاليه تحديد الفتره
الانتقاليه بمده 24 شهرا من تاريخ تعيين
رئيس وزراء مدني يتراس حكومه انتقاليه
تفكيك نظام الرئيس عمر حسن البش ير في كل
مؤسسه الدوله استرداد الاموال والاصول
المتحصل عليها بطرق غير شرعيه الى اخره
لكن واحد من هذه البنود كانت تاكيد على
تكوين جيش قومي مهني موحد وملتزم بالعقيده
العسكريه الموحده وهذا يقتضي توحيد قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات ميليشيات اخرى يتم
دمجها في الجيش الوطني السوداني وهنا بدات
بذره الخلاف بين القوات الدعم السريع
والجيش او بمعنى اصح تصل ذروه الخلاف ما
بين الدعم السريع والجيش لان الخلف كان
موجودا لاسباب كثيره منها انه كان
الفريق حميتي
والدعم السريع الاتفاق الاطاري وضع جدولا
زمنيا ينتهي في 11 ابريل الماضي باختيار
رئيس وزراء علشان يقود حكومه مدنيه تقود
المرحله الانتقاليه لمده 24 شهر وكان
المفروض ان قبل 11 ابريل يكونوا اتفقوا
على مساله
قوات دمج قوات الدعم السريع مساله ليست
عسيره وليست صعبه لانه الجيش عنده تصور
بدا له معقولا ايه التصور ده انه الفتره
الانتقاليه سنتين يبقى فتره دمج الدعم
السريع للجيش تبقى حوالي سنتين والمساله
ميسوره كيف يمكن ان ندمجه واحد النوقف
التجنيد تجنيد عناصر جديده للدمج الدعم
السريع والدعم السريع كان بيعمل عمليه
تجنيد زي الجيش
نوقف عمليه التجنيد ده واحد اتنين في عدد
من ضباط وجنود الجيش السوداني الحقوا على
الدعم السريع باعتباره كان احد يعني اجهزه
وفروع القوات المسلحه يتم اعادتهم بنفس
رتبهم الى القوات المسلحه يتبقى الافراد
والضباط الذين يخدمون في الدعم السريع ولم
يتم الحقهم وبعض السودانيين بيقولوا ان
بعضهم ليس سودانيه من الاصل بيقولوا هؤلاء
سوف ينضموا الى الجيش السوداني بعد اعاده
النظر في رتبهم يعني اذا كان شخص بيحمل
رتبه عقيد او عميد ينظروه في مؤهلاته هل
تسمح له بحمل هذه الرتبه ام انه شخص لم
يحصل على اي مؤهلات وحصل على هذا
وحصل على هذه الرتبه لاي اسباب راها محمد
حمدان ديجلو اذا كانت ليست لديه المؤهلات
وفقا لقواعد الجيش يعد تاهيله وينضم برتبه
مناسبه الى الجيش محمد حمدان دجله وقياده
قوات الدعم السريع رفضت هذه التصورات
وقالت انه الضباط والجنود ينضمون الى
الى الجيش بنفس رتبهم دون اعاده النظر
فيها
يستمر التجنيد مفتوحا كما هو لانه وهذا هو
الاهم ان محمد حمدان دجله يرغب في الا تتم
عمليه الدعم خلال عامين وطالب بفتره اطول
تتجاوز العشر سنوات وهو ما رفضته قوات
الجيش تماما ورفضته قوى سياسيه اخرى ده
معناه انه حاجه من اتنين تنتهي عمليه
الانتقال السياسي تمشي في مسار ويصبح هناك
محمد حمدان دقله خارج هذا المسار يقود
ميليشيا بعشرات الالاف وعنده زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم شركاته وعنده يعني طموحاته
السياسيه ويصبح دوله داخل الدوله او انه
تتعطل عمليه الانتقال السياسي تماما بدل
ما تبقى سنتين تبقى اكتر من عشر سنوات الا
ان هناك فريق يرى انه لا جدوى من اتمام
عمليه انتقال سياسي فيما ان البلد فيها
جيشين
وبالتالي بدات الخلافات الخلافات دي
تصاعدت في الفتره الاخيره لتصاعدت في
الفتره الاخيره مره اخرى لانه شهر ابريل
كان في المواقيت النهائيه لعمليه البدء في
تنفيذ الاتفاق الاطاري اللي احد اهم بنوده
الاتفاق على حسب موقف الدعم السريع
ووصلت هذه الخلافات الى ذروتها حين اراد
كل طرف فرد رؤيته على الطرف الاخر بما ان
انا مش قادرين نتفاهم فكل الطرف بدا يطلق
التهديدات وانه قادر على تدجين الطرف
الاخر واخضاعي واندلعت المواجهات في يوم
السبت
اللي هو امس 15 ابريل 2023 بعد الخبراء
بعد المهتمين بشان السوداني كان عندهم
تفسيرات اخرى مثلا صديقي دكتور محمد طرشين
على سبيل المثال كان بيعتقد انه تحركات
ديجلو لم يكن هدفها تقليم اظافر الجيش لان
دي مغامره كبيره هو كان اراد انه يتحرك
بطول البلاد وعرضها لفرض ضغوط عند التفاوض
لكنه هناك صخور داخل الجيش كانوا عازمين
على القضاء على
دعم السريع باي ثمن وراوا في هذه التحركات
سببا كافيا لبدء المواجهه معه وبالمناسبه
انا يعني بشكر الدكتور محمد كثيرا لانه
ساعدني في اعداد هذه الحلقه بارائه النيره
كالعاده وكذلك الدكتور الكبير واستاذي
الدكتور سيد فليفل اللي يتحدث عما اشار
اليه من اراء المهمه في حلقه اللاحقه باذن
الله على كل الاحوال هذه الخلفيه التي ادت
الى اندلاع الاحداث الان المواجهه
مفتوحه في طول البلاد وعرضها معظم من
تحدثت اليهم يعتقدوا ان المواجهه محسومه
للجيش وانا سوف تكون مواجهه سريعه
ولكن من قبيل التحفظ ولانه هناك تجارب
سابقه سواء في الجيش السوداني او لجيوش
اخرى بدات المهمه سهله لكنها اخذت اكثر
بكثير مما كان متوقعا لها فمن باب التحفظ
نقول انه المواجهه الان مفتوحه على
مصراعيها نتائجها ليست معلومه
وان شاء الله مع تطورات هذه المواجهه
الخطيره تكون لنا حلقات اخرى نرصد فيها ما
يجري وما الت اليه هذه المواجهات ونرصد
ايضا البعد الخارجي الذي يلعب دورا مهما
جدا في الصراع الدائري الان في السودان
اشكركم والى لقاء